So if we treat fragments
as mini activities,
each with its own
independent life cycle in UI,
how does that compare
to the life cycle of a real activity?
Well as you might expect,
the basic life cycle events
are much the same
as the parent activity.
And as it moves
through the cycles of starts,
resumes, pauses, and stops,
those same life cycle events
will be triggered
within the fragment itself.
So, in most cases,
you can simply move anything
that you would have put
into the activities life cycle handles,
into the corresponding
fragment handles.
With, of course, a couple of exceptions.
Rather than building your UI
here and onCreate,
fragments introduced a new event
specifically for this.
OnCreateView is where you construct
or inflate your UI,
hook up to any data sources,
and return it to the parent activity
which can then integrate it
into its view hierarchy.
There's a corresponding
onDestroy view handler,
which is called immediately
before the fragment is added
to the back stack,
independent of the parent activity.
Now keep in mind that
the FragmentManager
can add any fragment transactions
adding, removing,
or replacing fragments
to the back stack,
with a single parent
activity's actives.
So a fragment can move
through this cycle
multiple times
independent of the host activity.
So onDestroy view is,
where you should clean up
any resources specifically
related to the UI,
such as bitmaps in memory,
cursors to data,
anything like that to help ensure
that your app's memory footprint
isn't bloated by data
that's not needed
when the fragment isn't visible.
Now as soon as the fragment
is returned from the back stack,
on CreateView is called,
and you can re-create the UI
and reconnect data sources
before your fragment transitions
through the rest of the life cycle
to become active again.
And because a fragment
can only exist within an activity,
we also need callbacks
to tell us when a fragment
is attached and detached
from its parent.
OnAttach is your opportunity
to get a reference
to the parent activity.
While onDetach is the last thing
that happens,
even after your fragment
has technically been destroyed.
Now, the final piece of the puzzle
is onActivityCreated.
This notifies our fragment
that the parent activity
has completed its
OnCreate handler
and represents the point
at which we can safely interact
with its UI, potentially
including other fragments.
Now, just like the activity lifecyle
we discussed in lesson three,
once the fragment
is no longer visible,
there's a chance
it will be terminated
with no further code being executed.
That can happen, after onStop,
in the case of the activity
being terminated
while the fragment is part
of that activity's view hierarchy,
or after onDestroyView,
if the fragment has already
been placed in the back stack
once the activity is destroyed.